let's now go from the reaction to the
Las Vegas mass shooting by Steven
paddock from the NRA to that by
Christian extremist vile televangelist
Pat Robertson Pat Robertson hosts the
700 club it's been a while since we
actually talked about Pat Robertson so
to catch you up some of the things that
Pat Robertson has said during his
bizarre tenure as host of the 700 club
he once said that men with rebellious
wives should live where wife-beating is
legal because well do I really need to
explain why that second-hand clothes can
come with demons attached that abortion
is a lesbian conspiracy that atheists
are trying to steal Christmas to make
you miserable reminds me of a children's
book actually that divorce is wrong
unless your wife gets sick and he has
this great list of different items that
over the years he said ken or our
demonic and that includes feng shui
Ouija boards yoga karate horoscopes
Twilight paintings of Buddha television
shows about ghosts Halloween psychics
obviously young girls who levitate their
friends at sleepovers and sometimes
sometimes even adopted children from
other countries can have demons attached
and that sort that's a real problem
that's just a partial list I don't have
two hours to give you the full list of
Pat Robertson's claims over the years so
back to yesterday Pat Robertson is now
blaming what is the worst mass shooting
in American history perpetrated by
Steven paddock in Las Vegas late Sunday
evening which happened not even 48 hours
ago mind you on the fact that he
believes people are disrespecting Donald
Trump and disrespecting the National
Anthem
I couldn't possibly explain it as as
well as Pat Robertson so here he is
explaining it to us violence in the
streets ladies and gentlemen why is it
happening you know what I'd like to give
you is the fact that we have disrespect
for authority there is profound
disrespect of our president all across
this nation they say terrible things
about him it's in the news it's in other
places
there's disrespect now for our
lanthum disrespect for our veterans
disrespect for the institutions of our
government disrespectfulness of the
court system all the way up and down the
line disrespect and when you lose that
kind of respect you lose this Authority
but more than anything until there is
biblical authority there has to be some
controlling Authority in our society and
there is none and when the there is no
vision of God that people say there's no
vision of God the people run amok when
there is no vision of God the people run
amok so I want to focus on the second
part of what he said but just to give
you the list again
the causes of this shooting in Las Vegas
according to Pat Robertson were
disrespect for authority disrespect for
the president disrespect for the
national anthem for our veterans for the
institutions of our government for the
court system up and down the line and
then he calls for Christian Sharia law
right I mean we says we need biblical
authority this is no different than
someone calling for actual Islamic
sharia law it's just a different flavor
of it what Pat Robertson is saying is
that we we need that authority from God
to be our daily sort of ruling law
that's no different from the most
extreme Muslim Imams and religious
figures the difference is Pat Robertson
says that while wearing a suit on ABC
Family and the other channels that air
his show during the 700 club instead of
standing at the front of a mosque that's
the only difference
this is extremist clergy period it's
what Isis would say full stop I mean I
don't I don't have to qualify it any
further
Isis uses attacks like what we saw in
Las Vegas to push their agenda and Pat
Robertson use it too it uses it to push
a slightly different agenda but one that
is not altogether different in terms of
it's it's sort of fundamental qualities
and requirements Pat Robertson has
accumulated a net worth of between
there's different estimates between 200
million dollars and a billion dollars
this stuff pays if I were a religious
man I would wonder
doesn't pat robertson's existence
doesn't the fact that pat robertson
became this wealthy off of religious
nonsense of this caliber proof that
there is no god what type of God would
allow Pat Robertson to become this rich
from PETA preaching hate and extremism
that that's that's a certainly something
that we've talked about before with
regard to the Las Vegas shooting of
course it's actually hugely
disrespectful to the victims to say the
problem is disrespect of Trump or the
fact that we don't have a formal
biblical authority in our country
because it makes it seem as if if only
we were more pious if only we were more
devoted to his pick of the religions
right if we if we were only more devoted
to Jesus 59 or whatever the number is of
people at this point a growing number
horribly wouldn't wouldn't be dead right
now and four or five hundred people
wouldn't be injured that's a it's the
height of insensitivity and we should
all be disgusted by what pat robertson
is saying